Speaker 1: So let's talk about Vladimir Putin.
As many of you remember, we started talking about
the Putin's health story a while ago at the very
start of the invasion of Ukraine by Russia. We got
emails from a couple of doctors who said, Putin
doesn't look good. Putin looks sick. We could be
looking at any number of different conditions. And
I said to all of you, this is speculation. This
is mere idle speculation. We then saw about
ten days ago this video of Vladimir Putin,
where he is sitting at a table. He's gripping the
table almost for support. He's, like pushed back
against the chair. He's tapping his toe. His left
hand is shaky. And this renewed speculation that
there could be something very seriously wrong with
Vladimir Putin in the last 48 hours, a story came
out in the British tabloid The Sun that Putin is
going to be having cancer surgery. And I didn't
come to you with the story because the sun is
simply not an appropriate source for our show.
That story now has made it into The New York Post.
Now, I still come to you with caution and I say
The New York Post is basically the print version
of Fox News. It's still not a slam dunk that the
truth is exactly as is being reported here.
But this is now becoming mainstream enough
that since we've been talking about
it at this point for over a month,
I want to talk about it with you. The New York
Post story says Putin to undergo cancer surgery
and transfer power to the ex FSB chief. Russian
President Vladimir Putin is set to undergo cancer
surgery and temporarily hand over power to a
hard line former federal police chief, according
to a new report. Putin will transfer control
of Russia's government to Nikolai Patrushev,
head of the Russian Federal Police's Security
Council, while he is incapacitated during and
after the procedure, according to a video from
the mysterious Telegram Channel. General SVR,
the channel is purportedly run by a former
Russian foreign intel service. Lieutenant general
reported that Putin has been told by doctors he
must undergo an operation. The anticipated surgery
and recovery are expected to incapacitate Putin
for a short time, according to the unconfirmed
report. Putin is unlikely to agree to hand
over power for a longer period of time.
I will say that this is the worst
option. Patrushev is an outright villain,
no better than Putin. Moreover, he's more cunning
and I would say more insidious than Putin.
If he comes to power, Russian's problems will
only multiply. So is this true? We don't really
know. We don't really know. But what we do know
is at this point, speculation from doctors,
video evidence and this kind of strange report
all are saying the exact same thing. And
whether this is responsible for Putin's actions
in Ukraine is a different story altogether. And
the reason that the speculation is related
to the invasion of Ukraine would be, well,
if he believes that he's going to die, he
may try to go out in a sort of final blaze of
trying to restore glory to the former
Soviet Union, as he still idolizes it,
or it may be a side effect of medication that is
making him irrational. There are also unconfirmed
reports that this is actually a cognitive
issue and dementia. It's it's wild speculation
at the micro level. But the macro story continues
to be more and more different types of stories
about Putin's health. So all we can do is wait and
see. And I don't even know that there's more to
say about it. But the story creeping, creeping,
creeping more and more into the mainstream.